I'm Harry Mack and this is the wired
autocomplete interview
I haven't seen any of the questions yet
I think we're just going to Freestyle
this whole thing let's get it
[Music]
oh yeah yeah I believe in the floor we
bout to get started here with the first
boy I got rappers running something like
Scaredy Cats I told them I'm Harry Mack
they said what Harry Met well now I'm
about to prove him here's the first
question when I rhyme I prove the flow's
impression yeah hey yo I'm on the
lyrical run they want to know what Harry
Mack has done well let me think I came
off top with the freeze I put my lyrics
together with ease yeah I was spitting
it clean and my friend Jacob's car back
in 2016. that's the first time I had a
video go low-key viral 100K views was
vital it lit the fire inside me to live
my dream and finally help me boost up my
own self-esteem started my own channel
2017 proved I'm the rhyme manners with
freestyling Adventist Beach all the fans
stayed Within Reach they came and they
gathered round so that I could teach and
that video went crazy as well all across
the internet it helped my name to Excel
and prepare tell me the opportunities to
rap fast and have a blast while rhyming
with Joey Badass next thing I know I'm
getting invented with bars while I'm
spitting next to Kendrick Lamar shouts
out to the cruise show for putting me on
so I could rhyme off top prove I'm a
lyrical done yeah and after that
couldn't nobody tell them no had the
opportunity to rhyme on The Ellen Show
uh I was underground like a sewer but
from these opportunities now we out on
tour it's incredible hey yo y'all know I
stay thankful just to have these
opportunities now I'm grateful hey yo we
bout to move on to question two a brand
new answer what I'm about to pursue uh
y'all know I'm here to spill Flames yeah
they asking what is Harry Mack's real
name oh well I get my Mac when I kick
these lyrics on a frenzy but really my
last name's Mackenzie yeah other MCS is
about to Envy it's funny cause Mackenzie
spelled with the MC which makes sense
cause I'm a Master of Ceremonies uh
every time I rhyme it's like they barely
know me but here's what's funny I don't
spell it m-a-c-k there's no no actual
Mac in my last name to see hey it's all
gravy we gonna switch it up regardless
cause when it becoming the lyrics they
know Mac goes the hardest what is a
hairy Mac fill in the blank uh to be on
stage yo I gotta get fast uh I like the
fuse then I bomb the mic they said what
is a hairy mad constant like yo it's
like nothing that you felt in your life
it's me on stage straight melting the
mic and my DJ sir Jazz pulling out all
the cuts so I can grip the mic you're
mentally erupt we got a QR code you can
submit your words and submit your topic
so my brain can go absurd I mean when it
comes to rhyming ain't nobody been this
live I hop on stage and the whole sets
improvise yeah my fans stay strong
forever we collaborator we cook up the
songs together so what I mean to say for
me to do what I do would be absolutely
impossible without you shout out to
everybody watching and giving
inspiration y'all know we bout to win
the game by every indication what Harry
Mack does is this he comes off the
mantle with that fly freestyle twist
let's now
all right
oh yeah okay this is Board number two ah
check the way that we send this through
hey yo where's Harry Mack
from off the top where you're about to
get it done peace to all my friends and
family that support and no I was born in
the city of Portland I know they
wondering which one my flow is insane
they like you talking about Portland
Maine well hip hop is my main thing up
in my life but I'm from Portland Oregon
y'all better know that's right yeah when
they become a divorced people know that
I'm more fresh hmac be healing from the
Pacific Northwest I'll be living my
insane extremes I'm like the weather up
in Portland I'm a rain Supreme yeah
raining on the daily I was in my
basement downstairs with the drum set to
Jason we couldn't run around and play
outside cause every single day had the
grayish Skies so instead I was
practicing my rhythm making beats
writing Rhymes working on my vision
that's when I learned to use my
freestyle intuition now all up in this
game imma cause a collision it says uh
I'll be rocking for the people when does
Harry Mack go up on Omegle now every
time I rhyme you know I speak fast but
it's top secret dog I can't leak that
yeah we be on there looking for
strangers anytime I step these rappers
are in danger wish I could tell you but
can't nobody touch me hop up for an
Omegle who knows you might get lucky now
why does Harry Mack let's see come off
the top with totally these fresh freeze
when it comes to lyrics they know my
bars stay rare why does Harry Mack have
all the gray hair is he working magic
colder than a blizzard is he like
Gandalf is this dude a wizard how old is
he yo is he like 60 man I think the
industry don't even get me honestly I
grip up on the mic so I can bless and
I'm putting on my corny competition to
the test I told you I hail from the
Pacific Northwest I got gray hairs cause
these white rappers got me stressed yeah
y'all know I'ma striking like lightning
when it becoming the lyrics they love
what I'm providing will Harry Mack rip
off the last tape every time I spit
y'all know I go ahead when I spit they
know the lyrics straight fly they said
will Harry Mack use a I I mean in my
world it might be relevant but there's
nothing artificial official about my
intelligence I get hyped and then I
might stage dive my music crossing over
just like AI That's Alan Iverson I rap
easily in fact I cook up faster than
chat GPT rappers never seeing me check
how hype I get open up my skull and my
brain there's a microchip yeah I grabbed
the mic and then I grab you I got the
chip from the Apple M2 too futuristic
they can't get rid of bro I paint the
image off the tip like cars from Nvidia
y'all know these other rappers gotta
sweat it I'm the freestyle computer ai's
already embedded let's go
[Music]
oops
thank you
oh okay uh yeah they saying does Harry
Mack yeah the fans love Terry Matt okay
when I be rapping they know that I'm
crowd arousing all of the fans be asking
this every Mac have a album uh y'all
know I answer this one easy content's
Under Pressure that's the name of my EP
yeah and plus we drop mad compilations
of freestyles from the internet that's
dominating but I be recording my music
I'm working on that all the time so in
the coming months y'all can't expect
some more shine I'm about to put it down
for y'all questions getting answered we
do it in the form of a freestyle stanza
uh killing it right off the top of the
mantle imagine that all of the people
asking cause Mac paddle rap man I'm
making rappers pay the price but I'm not
about battling I'm just too nice yeah
shout out to the battle is they gotta
get live but see Mac I'm all about them
Positive Vibes uh but all the better at
freestyles online y'all know the get in
chat so to other Legends of that battle
rap scene I send respect uh shout out to
Immaculate yeah shouts of thesaurus
shout to the legend disaster this is
what we need tomorrow yeah as for me I
would rather decipher I just spit right
off the top and help rappers get hyped
for yeah hmac taking over with flavors
this dominant I'm more the type to hit
somebody with a compliment like nice
shirt I bless you with a nice verse
every time I spit off top you know my
mic's heard I'm about to throw it on
down cause the people go wild so many
different styles compiled hmac you
compete my fire mission and life is
making y'all smile yeah we be spreading
all kinds of Joy when I'm finished
rocking fans making all kinds of noise
oh hey yo I got my competition trembling
they wanna know if Harry Mack is friends
with Eminem does Eminem know me I can't
be certain but I can tell you this much
yo I didn't hurt him so many times
playing the CDs on repeat and studying
the way this do is such a beast on the
beat yeah but he ain't never
acknowledged me thus far it makes me
nervous thinking about him hearing my
bars I mean I'm in my own shadow and I'm
trying to blast off but I can't imagine
being peep by the Rap God I'm about to
break it down y'all know that my
freestyle's crazy uh throwing shaded
rappers so I leave them Shady yeah can't
nobody Rock This Way Matt connect to
beats like M to Dr Dre okay breaking it
down at the tip of the Dome every time
that a rhyme and I get in the zone y'all
don't crazy whenever I'm rapping
hopefully we can make this happen hmm
maybe Eminem watch is wired maybe he can
hear this fire maybe he can hear what
I'm doing right now and feel just a
little inspired I know if I could
depress I'm doing my best I know that I
refer the West the mama crash y'all know
that I'm taking a foreign shirt with the
bars everybody hating the God but Imma
Keep It In Motion they'll be overdosing
armor Maneuvers smooth and lotion I'll
be here for the Wyatt I don't feel y'all
know we got that devotion
all right here we go
yeah okay ah yeah yeah come on oh yeah
yeah okay listen uh-huh yeah hey yo pay
close attention cause I'm about to spit
the flow what is Harry Mack's most
viewed video uh yeah the answer that is
hard son but I'm pretty sure it's still
Venice Beach part one yeah I would have
to say I just grip on the mic and I
blast the phrase I put it down for all
my people then again my lyrics Beyond
hype most viewed it might be prom night
if you my fan then you know the
reference hmac go in places others never
win I did some free steams and made it
look easy for my gorilla bar series out
in DC yeah we was outside of the
monument oh and lyrics what I was
promising I saw a whole group of kids
that was about to go to Prime they was
having a photo shoot they outfits were
strong yeah a bunch of teenagers and
tuxedos I said bars for these kids we
gonna need those they started looking
over they started to give props they
recognized me they see me on Tick Tock I
said this is amazing the photographer
she turned and about me she wanted to
learn she said come on down hey yo we
bout to do it big she said Mac do you
want to kick some rounds for the kids I
said
um well yes I do I'm a grip up on this
mic and imma test this crew they all
threw out words and I started to recite
freestyles they was yelling I was so
hype we was bouncing tuxedos looking
clean on the scene I was coming up with
all the cadences and spitting in me at
the end the reaction was oh so loud
stood back in my b-boy pose feeling
proud that's the most viewed going deep
and still on Tick Tock now hmac married
to the game yo I took the vowels ah
first video well this one is easy imma
kick it true cause y'all know I'm not
deceiving oh hey yo y'all got me feeling
proud now first vid 2016. it's called
Bounce House yeah yeah I start to roam
well aside from all the home videos at
the home yeah bounce house was the first
I prove that I'm a crazy man rocking
crazy jams sitting next to homie Jacob
man it wasn't for mine I didn't have a
channel but sitting next to him I left
the microphone dismantled we drove down
Sunset I rap about what I saw I did my
best to kick the funky Rhythm keep it
raw 100K views overnight thanks to
Reddit and now I double down I'm staying
indebted to the car spitting raw third
question getting revealed every time I
spit I'd be deep up in my Fields Harry
Mack rap battles that would be nice but
I told y'all I don't battle and it's
only happened twice once I was in
seventh grade way before I ever heard my
records play I battled this dude who was
smoother than silk he was a year younger
in sixth grade his name is milk still a
dope wrap up in Portland and he's
killing it he was running very well and
they was feeling it I did my thing I
tried to bring the heat but his fans was
going way crazier and I got beat can
y'all imagine what that did to Harry's
confidence seventh grade deep my sixth
grader that's dominant hey yo it's flow
is prominent I had to learn never step
into the battle unless you gonna make
them burn second time it happened was in
college hey yo I ripped that dude that
has gotta be acknowledged but I told
y'all I'm not about battling as a beast
I'm all about spreading joy and filling
y'all with peace let's go uh y'all know
where the disasters at they said Harry
Max we need a faster rap that's what
we're gonna have to have happen indeed I
mean we need to hear you increase your
rapid speed I said okay well I'ma turn
it up and rip this so imma go from the
16s and turn it up to the triplets I
never return that I rhyme right off of
the mental I'm getting specific I'm
killing the whole entire game you know
that the most deliberate matter of fact
I might go to double time cause when it
comes delivers up into a subtle rhyme
age might be coming up the top of the
Dome every time then I'm rapping I'll be
locked in the zone I'm gonna do it to
the camera double times three push the
pedal to the battle and I'm never gonna
set a line go against the grain on the
freestyle Rebel no puppets I know your
pedal now I gotta slow it down so y'all
could peeping when it come to speed
switches Harry goes the deepest that's
the secret y'all better learn to throw
right we on wired right now Max burning
the mic it's like
huge shout out to the wired audience
it's a whole nother level of challenge
for me as a freestyler to try to be
coherent when answering complex
questions and try to you know be fluent
when expressing more complicated ideas
like this in a narrative kind of way so
super fun for me hope y'all enjoyed it
thank you so much for being here we love
you thank you
foreign